Speaker 1: The right wing hate mob that has been
unleashed against me by donald trump jr. And
candace owens and others. Listen, i'm a big boy. I
can take comments on twitter, right? But they are
going after our advertisers and they actually are
succeeding to some degree. Some advertisers have
already canceled. They don't know what's going
on. They're just getting thousands of emails
from people on the right who don't even watch this
show, but have been weaponized by people like Don
Jr and Candace Owens over my tweet regarding
the Nashville shooting, wherein I was blaming
those who offer only thoughts and prayers
and nothing else. Now, as I've said before,
it is a fine legal tactic to use to go to
a show's advertisers and say you shouldn't
advertise with this person. It was a tactic
that was used in the past with Tucker Carlson,
etc., but use it when it's appropriate. And
what is happening right now and we have we
have examples of this. I'm not going to put
a ton of them up, but if you look on Twitter,
all of these right wing and white nationalist
accounts are listing sponsors and then contacting
the sponsors and saying, these aren't my viewers,
nor are they customers of these brands. But they
are saying, you got to drop David Pakman. Now we
are doing everything we can to explain to them,
These aren't our viewers and these aren't your
customers. This is a concerted effort. In fact,
even Candace Owens is leading this effort to
some degree, tweeting, as I told you earlier,
to any of your advertisers who may be following
this, this is not a contrived mob. Yes, it is.
Or anti-Semitism. Look at my inbox, Candace.
This is you dealing with the consequences of
sending the most horrific, bigoted tweet directed
at dead Christian children who, according to you,
should have prayed harder. Of course not. My
point, I would never blame the victims of a mass
shooting. You all know that. But that's what they
want to make it out to be. So what we have now is
a situation where we know this is a contrived. The
video I did about the situation received nearly
100% likes versus dislikes because our audience
gets all of it. The people who aren't viewers
and aren't customers of these brands, though,
are having success. We already got emails from
multiple advertisers saying we are pausing,
advertising, pausing means it's over. Okay,
this is the most desperate situation we have ever
had over right wingers desperate not to deal with
gun safety because understand that that's what
this says. They would rather focus on anything
other than gun safety regulations to prevent
shootings in the future. That's what this is
about. And so instead, they're going after me.
They're more angry about a tweet I sent saying,
thoughts and prayers do nothing to stop shootings.
Then they are about the dead kids and now they're
going after my advertisers rather than trying to
fix the problem. So what you can do, number one,
right, to our advertisers, the ones you see
at the end of videos, write to them and say.
Please keep advertising with David. The people
emailing you angry aren't even his viewers, nor
are they your customers. Second. Subscribe to the
YouTube channel. If we can weather this with a big
increase in subscribers at a time when the right
is trying to end us. It would be huge. And the
most important thing is we have to replace that
revenue we have. This is no longer theoretical.
This is not about, you know, it's nicer to
get support from the audience because then
no one person can. Well, listen. We have a mix of
support from different sources. Advertisers are
one of those. And one person can say we're cutting
the campaign. And that's what's happening with a
number of these campaigns. It is not theoretical.
Help us make up for a slice of what these right
wing radicals have taken away through the ad
campaigns. You go to join Pacman dot com. We
have a coupon code. The code is cancel cancel,
cancel the counselors who say don't cancel people.
They are the ones who say don't use these
techniques, don't contact advertisers
demanding what they are now doing it.
Okay, The coupon code is cancel. Cancel.
This is genuinely a systemic threat to
The David Pakman Show. In a week's time,
I will come back to you and tell you if and to
what degree we have weathered it. Don jr. Quite
literally. Don jr is part of the hate mob trying
to end this show. That is the level that this has
now reached. So i'm coming to you for support.
My audience understands exactly what is going on.
Right to the advertisers. Subscribe to the YouTube
channel. Sign up at join Pacman dot com with the
coupon code. Cancel. Cancel. I will keep everybody
posted about what's going on. My hope is my hope
is that we actually come out of this even
stronger, which will really upset the right
wing mob. The David Pakman Show is a community
viewer and listener supported program that's never
been important, more important than right now,
as Donald Trump Jr and Candace Owens are quite
literally sending a right wing hate mob of online
attackers against us. I already spoke about it
earlier in the show. Bear in mind the importance,
the precarity of this situation. You can sign up
at join Pacman dot com and you can use the coupon
code cancel cancel to get yourself a discount.